à peine sorti de sa voiture le chant
d'un homme perturbe la visite d'Emmanuel
Macron à Amsterdam
es
[Musique]
a été arrêté pour trouble à l'ordre
public et menace tout comme une autre
manifestante qui se trouvait plus en
retraites
je suis fier de mon pays je suis fier de
mon Président d'ailleurs et de l'image
de la France qu'il renvoie à l'étranger
nous menons au Pays-Bas comme en France
des réformes difficiles qui soulève
parfois des protestations parfois en
France on pense qu'il n'y a que dans
notre pays qu'il y en a vous qui vivez
ici vous savez très bien qu'il y en a
ici aussi
forte profonde le président français
cible également du langage fleuri de
Donald Trump il a tout simplement accusé
Emmanuel Macron de Macron
donc oui la France ne soutient pas les
provocations ne soutient pas la
politique fiction et considère que le
statut quo le respect et la clarté et le
meilleur allié de l'autonomie
stratégique européenne et de notre
vision des choses c'est pourquoi je ne
participerai pas aux commentaires et
n'aurait rien à dire sur les phrases de
l'ancien président Trump oui c'est
Donald Trump qui parle donc voilà c'est
pardon je me reconnais pas dans les
positions de Donald Trump ni hier ni
aujourd'hui ni demain et encore moins
dans ces mots parce que il participe de
cette escalade qui est recherché par
certains
quand il était Président je ne
commentais pas ces phrases je ne vais
pas le faire maintenant qu'il n'est plus
président
s de violences sexuelles
qui a mené l'enquête et recueilli le
témoignage de 13 femmes qui évoquent des
propos et des gestes déplacés sur des
tournages dans une tribune publiée sur
les réseaux sociaux intitulée la 5e
erreur Dominique Strauss-Kahn sort de
son silence pour critiquer sans jamais
le nommer Emmanuel Macron et pointe
quatre erreurs le manque de vision
globale
il faut sortir dit-il des vieux schémas
la méthode également la négligence
notamment des syndicats en tête la CFDT
et puis le passage en force il paraît
que Dominique Strauss-Kahn est très
intelligent s'il était à ce point il
comprendrait que tout le monde se fiche
de son avis il devrait se taire jusqu'à
la fin de sa vie et profiter du grand
air frais de la liberté
puisque les revenants sont nos intéresse
pas a été un ministre important de la
République française maintenant je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il n'est pas le mieux
qualifié pour donner des leçons de
politique pour finir Dominique
Strauss-Kahn dénonce l'usage
disproportionné de la violence physique
et cible les éléments de langage de
l'exécutif défendre des idées sociales
ne fait pas de nos concitoyens des
ultra-gauchistes écoutez et comprendre
la rue fait partie de la responsabilité
politique Dominique Strauss-Kahn fustige
enfin la stratégie d'Emmanuel Macron
celle du bras de fer avec les syndicats
et du passage en force par le 49.3 il
aurait pu bravement aller au vote quitte
à le perdre ce neurait certes pas été
glorieux mais la tension serait retombée
écoutez et comprendre la rue fait aussi
partie de la responsabilité politique a
été c'est que nous en fait tout ce qui
était dans notre pouvoir pour lutter
contre cette réforme des retraites nous
avions pris cet engagement près des
Français et nous l'avons fait nous avons
voté l'intégralité de l'émotion de rejet
nous avons déposé une motion
référendaire je crois qu'il est
clairement disqualifié pour pouvoir
juger de ce que la pertinence d'une
réforme
ce sont on fait de l'obstruction
c'est-à-dire la nups
nationale
de retraite ils
en pensent responsabilité inconstin
inquiétant les plus jeunes passent de
plus en plus de temps sur les écrans
c'est le résultat d'une étude qui suit
18000 enfants depuis leur naissance à
deux ans un petit Français passent
environ 56 minutes par jour devant un
écran
on se démonte pas les uns et les autres
on sait aussi que la hiérarchie elle
couvre ses dysfonctionnements contre le
faciès sous les violences policières
l'IGPN ça a été fait pour ça donc on est
au courant que l'IGPN c'est une grande
arnaque est faite pour couvrir mais
encore plus grave encore plus haut c'est
la classe politique qui couvre tout ça
c'est beaucoup plus que ce que
recommande l'Organisation mondiale de la
santé je vous en rappelle les consignes
pas d'écran avant 3 ans et maximum une
heure par jour ensuite